producer dr. Luke subpoenas Lady Gaga
this according to reports lawyers for
the 43 year old mega producer reportedly
filed court papers Friday night to have
the 31 year old singer set a deposition
date for his defamation case against
Ke$ha Gaga has been a vocal supporter of
Kesha since she claimed dr. Luke aka
Lucas gottwald allegedly sexually and
emotionally abused her
Luke's lawyer released this statement to
et regarding the court Doc's filed
Friday quote this motion has become
necessary because dr. Luke's counsel has
not been able to obtain despite repeated
requests a deposition date from Lady
gaga Gaga's rep replied in a statement
to billboard quote she has provided all
of the relevant information in her
possession dr. Luke's team is attempting
to manipulate the truth and draw press
attention to their case by exaggerating
Lady Gaga's role and falsely accusing
her of dodging reasonable requests et
has reached out to Gaga's reps for
comment stick with ET as this story
develops
[Music]